six months since the Taliban seized
power and the killings and other human
rights abuses have gone on multiplying
women have been a major Target their
peaceful protests broken up some have
been threatened beaten and disappeared
the Taliban had promised an inclusive
government but not a single woman was
appointed to the cabinet my guest this
week from Kabul is shapil Azam Taliban
director general of economic relations
at the foreign Ministry are you in the
Taliban capable of anything more
constructive than violence and
repression we are working on our police
forces before they were warriors for 20
years but after that they changed the
role of warrior two to the policemen
but what future are they building
sources tell VW that the drug trade is
booming and the Taliban is still taking
its cut as it has done for years
and will they crack down on some of the
world's most dangerous Terror groups
openly hosted in the country do they
really believe they can play nice with
Al-Qaeda and the West at the same time
that and much more on conflict Zone
[Music]
welcome to conflict Zone
nice to be with you the Taliban made a
lot of promises when it seized the power
last August and they've broken a lot of
them is there any reason why the world
should trust anything they say these
days
uh we know Taliban made or Islamic
Emirates made many promises but based on
their five or six months experience if
we see the changes actually it's totally
Dramatical to not only to foreign but as
well to advance and for 20 years money
propaganda has been made against Islamic
Emirate but while they come to the power
and they clearly show that to everyone
that these were rumors fake news and
propaganda all right let me just um pick
you up on that because you said they've
been rightly in power for almost a year
almost half a year the UN and other
human rights bodies continue to release
deeply disturbing reports of their human
rights violations aren't you ashamed of
that before this report a representative
of un hasn't had a a meeting with the
interim interior Minister and they said
they showed their satisfaction from
security and to all members of un uh as
well uh in sixth uh February we had a
meeting with you and all organizations
and they showed their satisfaction from
uh current new government that they
provided well security to all U.N
members
apart from U.N members your officials
claimed repeatedly there were amnesties
for those who worked for the previous
government and yet the UN has revealed
credible evidence that your Fighters
have gone on hunting down and killing
those who've already surrendered the UN
said just two months ago that between
August and November last year they
received evidence of more than a hundred
killings of former Afghan security
personnel and others associated with the
government 72 of those killings
attributed to the Taliban in several
cases the bodies of those victims were
publicly displayed how do you justify
those crimes attributed directly to the
Taliban
uh one thing should be considered that
since sixth month or at least if we want
to compare the situation there should be
some indicators to compare that with the
previous in a previous regime each
single day we were losing around 300
Afghans in both sides but that's not a
fair comparison I'm talking what you
about what you've done since since you
came to power I am coming to that I'm
coming to that based on policy level
based on policy level there is a clear
amnesty to everyone yes we can accept
that now we are not carrying Heritage of
20 years war but now right now we are
carrying Heritage of 43-year War yes in
some cases there would be some incidents
of violation but it doesn't mean it's a
policy of the government government is
following those cases and everyone would
be bringing to the justice so you your
Fighters are out of control is this what
you're telling me your Fighters are out
of control
no no no no no I can't believe you
ordered these killings or the fighters
are out of control which is it
all fighters are under control if there
were not we would be witness of hundreds
of killings in Afghanistan you know
better in 20 years money wrong thing
happened to everyone there would be
money uh private cases between different
parties but this is a Show's commitment
of the government and for the rest of
these violations government have a full
commitment and they will bring them to
the Justice how do we know that how do
we know that how do we know we only have
your word for that as far as your
Justice is concerned we have no idea
there's no
independent monitoring of that so we
only have your word for this
no no one thing is that International
Community expectation is totally high
they are not considering the current
situation we are not living in a western
country that was a calm for hundreds of
years still we move from a conflict Zone
to to the to the peace to the to the
stability yes there would be some
stability but this is a positive bind
that government have a full commitment
for that and still they have controlled
money cases you're only being measured
you're only being measured by the
promises that you've made not by any
other standards and you've broken a lot
of those promises as recently as last
month the United Nations reported
credible allegations of illegal
disappearances and set a growing number
of the taliban's political opponents are
being detained along with civil society
representatives and people who voice
descent children are also being detained
indefinitely clay you think that's fair
you think that's just
right now if you see if you compare the
propaganda against Islamic Emirate now
we have Free Press everywhere everyone
has their own vices yes in some cases
there would be some investigation
regarding something one thing is clear
in every government and every country
there is a rule for freedom of speech
for protest for everything everyone have
a right to rise their wise and protest
but they should not disrespect value of
the whole country and they should not do
an action to lead a country to
destabilization stability for current
government is the priority we are giving
we are going toward stability to bring
Security in our country and to to the
region and to International Community
yes in some cases in some cases their
government has a right to investigate
from everyone to to uh to bring everyone
to the Justice this is a right but one
thing is clear in policy level that
avron current government is completely
committed to the freedom of pris as they
mentioned recently uh they they cleared
their statement just they requested from
the media and for all users of that you
talk about well you talk about the
freedom of the press since August more
than 6 000 journalists have lost their
jobs eighty percent of female
journalists are no longer working you've
closed more than 40 percent of the media
outlets in the country instead of press
Freedom this looks as though you're
scared of the truth what makes you in
the Taliban so scared of the truth
Mr Sebastian you are a person that you
are completely aware from of one current
situation these journalists which they
have lost their job this is not because
the policy level or the policy the
policy let's look at the policy we have
your new journalism Code Media Outlets
are told they must prepare quote
detailed reports in coordination with
the government media and information
center why so you can censor the stories
is that the AIM
this coordination doesn't mean that they
should hide the realities
these coordination mean that everything
should be based on rules and regulation
based on the rules of Journalism in some
cases in some cases we have seen that
many are making propaganda because of
their personal interests to get Asylum
just uh
control on these issues is important for
government and from everywhere right now
we are requesting from media and many
other activities just they should
reflect what is real going in the ground
not what they are imagine so you show
respect you show respect do you for
freedom of the press and for journalists
this this wasn't on show last September
when journalists covering demonstrations
were rounded up and photos later showed
the backs of two reporters covered with
bruises and gashes from being whipped
with cables by your thugs does that
sound respectful to you
one thing should be clear listen to me
why you are a totally differentiate
African government from the other side
of the other uh countries the same
incident same thing can happen as well
in Western Country as well we have many
videos that how police of which European
countries U.S they are threatening women
about Afghanistan you can play the what
about game indefinitely what about other
places I'm talking to you about
Afghanistan
that's it any Behavior if any Behavior
Uh is not suitable to be done with the
protesters or many other activists it
doesn't mean that we are happy
government is Happy on that yes but in a
ground something can happen and it's
common everywhere but the problem is why
some TV channels some groups of
countries they are they made Afghanistan
underwatch they are broadcasting very
small issues in a very wide manner this
is a problem let's come to to the
reality to the neutrality consider
current situation of every country based
on that may calculation against them
we're talking we're talking about your
country and the concerns being expressed
and what is going on in your country
from the highest level the UN Secretary
General said last month he remained
extremely concerned about the fate of
several women activists who have been
abducted from their homes and have
disappeared no Afghan he said should
live in fear of a knock at their door in
the night and no family should be left
to wonder about the whereabouts and fate
of their loved ones but they are living
in fear aren't they and creating that
fear seems to have been your primary
achievement over the last half year are
you in the Taliban capable of anything
more constructive than violence and
repression because we've seen a lot of
that from you
uh
uh my point is this that every comments
or claims which is made on current
government just compared that to the
previous government which use NATO was
here and they were glorifying that we
are making a good governance here
compared to that I know you want to talk
about the other type of member we're
talking about yoga at that time as well
we're talking about U.S government right
you I know you want to change the
subject I I not I not reject that that
there would be no mystic
sure everything can happen everywhere
but based on policy level it's not the
policy the current government within
five minutes five months they control
money money better compared to the
previous regime this is achievement no
one is exposing this type of achievement
just they are making criticize in
something there would be some violations
we accept that there is some personal
cases some personal Behavior right now
we are working on our police forces
before they were warriors for 20 years
but after that they changed the role of
warrior two to the policeman right now
every single day if you ask from Kabul
citizen or many other citizens all over
the country there is a positive Movement
we have money progress in this situation
they provided will security to every
Avalon to foreigns which they are here
it's it's a unacceptable to everyone
compared
and a lot of concern being expressed at
high level Mr Azam the UN sees a pattern
in the taliban's behavior it talks of
arbitrary arrests and detentions as well
as torture and ill treatment of Civil
Society activists journalists and media
workers along with former government and
security forces Personnel that adds up
to a pretty shameful record doesn't it
this is not in a level act they are
expressing that in some cases I accept
that there would be some problems but it
doesn't shows the policy level in some
cases there are some groups are making
some videos they are making some
propaganders they can give you an
example of that right now Afghan
government didn't force no one no woman
to wear a burqa they LED them just they
say it as an advice that adjust yourself
based on Islamic and Afghan value but in
some cases some are coming they are
burning burkha what does it mean
actually this is an act of destabilizing
they are they are bringing pressure on
uh police that to show let me just make
that connection
you say nobody is being forced to wear
the hijab or the burqa that's simply not
true on February the 7th General mobeen
Khan spokesman for your Kabul police
said it's not up to the people to say we
choose the coverings we like no you do
what we prescribe period you do what we
prescribe and he added the taliban's
patience is running thin so Mr Azam they
are being forced and told what to wear
contrary to your comfortable assurances
if it is right right now ask from your
reporters and they should see Kabul
situation other City situation so why
this is not physically existence what
you are claiming actually this is not a
policy don't make an excuse of one
person as a policy policy is totally
different rights now Afghan government
he's a police spokesman for Kabul he's a
cowboy police spokesman he's not he's a
police spokesperson
maybe because of such claims which is
not representing policy of Afghan
government policy makers or others and
there are others which are implementing
the rules right now uh the the situation
which is provided within this fault
month this is totally
unexpected and Afghan government is
working to to regularize all activities
to bring uh that type of facilities and
services to avrants which they are in
need of that that meet their religious
and cultural values this is a very
positive changes and the women and the
women and the way women are being
treated is not a positive change the
fact is they become second-class
citizens pushed around forced to wear
what you decide study where you decide
work where you decide if at all can you
give me an example what gives you what
gives you the right I'll I'll give you
an example and I'll give you what the UN
Secretary General said about this
um just last month he said women
scientists lawyers and teachers are
locked out locked out wasting skills and
talents that will benefit the entire
country a generation of girls is seeing
its hopes and dreams shattered how does
this destroying the girls hopes and
dreams fit into your Islamic code please
answer that
this is not correct right so the U.N
Secretary General doesn't know what he's
talking about is that it listen to me I
I'm not talking about him let's let's
discuss about the fact I requesting you
do not rely only on reports you can see
the current reality which is going on
right now
uh University doors are open to to the
girls why you and why you are not
reflecting this positive signals
right now in jalalabat or in those areas
which are which have which have hot
season right now women are going there
right now male and men and women they
are registering their names to the
concur which the entrance door to to the
university right now they're registering
why you are not discussing about this
right now we have more than 15
000 womens working only in health sector
right now women are working and in our
past passport direct rate in identity
card direct trade in Kabul Airport or
many other areas yes there were some
projects some uh some other
organizations
the the only blame cannot refer to the
Taliban International donors they had
money uh economic projects they had many
other projects they cut their donation
welcome back to all the jobs they had
before no there isn't even a women's
ministry anymore because you closed that
down
in many countries there is no Ministry
for women it doesn't mean that the
current government ignoring them right
now before I give money example in money
Ministries in many organization they are
doing work they are providing services
to male and women
there is no policy for that let's talk
about the terrible food shortages the
humanitarian crisis facing your country
become what has become a daily nightmare
for people trying to feed their families
it wasn't until the first week of this
month that your first Deputy Prime
Minister called on government
departments to present plans for
tackling the crisis what have you been
doing for the last six months
regarding humanitarian AIDS there was a
concern for many years that take over by
coming Islamic we will lose values of
over 20 years achievements right now
Afghan government kept their system they
active its International Community they
are ignoring the system they are
destroying they are making a parallel
system which is difficult for them
difficult for them to distribute the
humanitarian assets or many others are
ignoring banking system Mr Azam let's
let's talk about the enormous illegal
drug trade in Afghanistan that the
Taliban has warned that this huge
criminal Enterprise will have to stop
does that also apply to the Taliban as
well since they've been cashing in on
the drugs trade in parts of Afghanistan
for a very long time are they going to
stop
trading in illegal narcotics as well
come to come to the policy right now all
narcotic uh business or trades is going
through our Nanny banking system right
now Afghan government is totally
committed for re-establishing supporting
banking system but something about the
drug business I'm talking about the drug
business I'm asking whether your own
fighters are going to stop dealing in
drugs and taking taxes from it last year
a report to the U.N security Council
said the production and trafficking of
drugs remained the taliban's largest
single source of income again how does
that fit in with your Islamic principles
these reports were available as well
about the previous government as well
but you can say the policy of Avon
current government in their previous
period which they have a government how
they brought this business to zero
you're not answering my questions you're
not answering my question he writes now
I can say the situation would be money
money better from a government which was
supported by by U.S NATO I can clearly
guarantee that I can clear granji now
right now our one government is working
to provide alternative to an agriculture
sections if International Community
really it's their concerns they should
support our agriculture section there
would be no business there would be no
harvesting of Narcotics can we can we
also real about their concern they
should support our agriculture sector Mr
Azam can we expect the Taliban will also
fail to keep its promise to prevent
terrorist groups in your country from
launching attacks outside Afghanistan
you're still very friendly with Al-Qaeda
your two groups have even intermarried
many of their leaders are based in
Afghanistan and the Border region how
exactly do you intend to prevent them
launching attacks
clear example is available
compared to the previous report always
they were criticizing that more than 20
terrorist groups are active in
Afghanistan actually these groups rised
and burned under U.S Natural Forces but
regarding daesh forces while Islamic at
the same time in a fighting against
previous Afghan regime U.S Natural
Forces they proved they proved that they
eliminated daesh from all over the
country this was Afghan government this
was International Community
we're talking about Al-Qaeda
I clearly said based on Doha agreement
Afghan current government government
have a full commitment there would be no
threats to avarance they will not allow
every single groups to make a threats to
other countries this is a full
commencement
to train on your territory you allow
them to train on your territory the UN
report recently said that under your
rule these terrorists enjoy greater
freedom in Afghanistan than at any time
in recent history and there are no signs
you've taken steps to limit their
activities why totally baseless totally
incorrect so they just don't understand
I'm confused about these Union reports
while their representative are coming
and they are discussing what our
ministry of interior Ministry of Defense
they are saying well Securities provided
will situation in everywhere but on the
other side those reporters I don't know
who are there uh from where they are
receiving this type of reports clearly I
can say this is the policy of current
government we want to make a stable
country
in state of conflict Zone we are going
to to the zoon of national interest to
the zoon of economic interest we want to
reconnect a big project of our neighbors
and Regional this is the policy at the
same time with this policy we cannot
support those groups which are making
threats to others yes there are many
Heritage from 20 years Afghan government
is fighting against them and we will
provide a secure environment for all and
whisters you want you want a secure
environment you want to secure
environment in a stable country by
hosting some of the most dangerous
terrorist groups in the world
you think the West is going to watch you
and expect you to play nice with those
terrorist groups and with them at the
same time you really think the West's
going to accept that
it's totally rejected by avran
government they called on in to please
in case
instead of blaming making excuse provide
a proof to the government based on that
if Government didn't take action they
can claim on that all right for 20 to 30
years there was a huge propaganda
against Avon government let's if we want
to have a stable country and and to not
be a threat to to the neighbor to the
region and Country let's support Afghan
government they have a good plan for
region for Afghanistan main focuses
economic development in Afghanistan
let's support let's give a chance all
right thanks very much for being on
conflict Zone thank you appreciate your
time my pleasure thank you so much
[Music]
thank you